a new report highlights the intense
pressure on young women to share nude
photos of themselves researchers at
Northwestern University analyzed nearly
500 stories on an anti cyberbullying and
sexting campaigns website more than
two-thirds of girls aged 12 through 18
said they had been asked for explicit
images researchers say the girls faced
persistent requests anger and threats
from boys to send those pictures
psychologists and CBS News contributor
Lisa d'amour writes about the study this
morning in a New York Times article
called teenagers stop asking for nude
photos she says it's time to quote
recalibrate some of the toxic norms that
have taken hold among teenagers Lisa
good morning good morning so what do
teen women face when they decline to
send nude photos of themselves well so
what this research article documented is
that when girls say no they are often
been pressured they're asked repeatedly
they sometimes face harassment they
sometimes face threats they're sometimes
cut off from relationships that this has
been going on among teenagers for a
while I really respect these researchers
for bringing it to light made us
something I hear about from the
teenagers I work with but it's something
that teenagers and teenage girls have
largely largely dealt with alone this is
defined as a new relational norm though
I think it's shocking to a lot of people
who were not aware it was even going on
but how does that end well I think
there's lots of ways it ends one is
obviously bringing it to light I think
the other thing is we've made a practice
of saying to teenagers don't send nude
photos like this is something adults are
saying we have not made a practice of
saying don't ask for nude photos right
and so one of the important things we
need to do at this point is we need to
recalibrate that norm and set rules
around this and the research also shows
that a lot of girls feel pressured to
send these photos what are some of the
conversations that parents and teachers
can be having with their children well
so I think what we need to say to our
kids whether we're in the role of
schools or parents is we need to say
look don't send nude photos it puts you
in an awkward position personally
socially maybe legally and we are saying
that so far then we need to say don't
ask for nude photos it puts somebody
else in right jirobo position
to do so you talked about this harmful
premise as well that you know boys play
offense girls play defense talk about
that so you know it's interesting I've
been a practicing psychologist for a
long time and one of the things I had to
come to terms with is that when I've
talked with teenagers and when a lot of
us talk with teenagers usually the
subtext is alright ladies we're going to
ask you to regulate adolescent sexuality
because we're not going to ask the boys
and that's something I have changed in
my own work with teenagers and I think
it's something we need to change when we
talk about teenagers and two teenagers
in general which is that we're going to
ask them to be fair and equitable both
boys and girls in terms of how they
handle themselves in these relationships
Lisa how old should children be when
parents start having those conversations
well it's interesting this research
started with twelve year olds right who
were saying they were getting requests
for photos so I think you know you
probably want to get out ahead of it and
you made the second you hand over a
phone to a teenager you know there are a
lot of rules you want to make I think a
great rule is don't do anything with
this phone you wouldn't want your
grandmother to see right that's a good
generic way I start it but then I think
you know it's time to sort of start
moving that conversation up as kids move
into sixth seventh eighth grade where we
really hear about this happening young
when you hear about people sexting in
the digital age and their response to
you is this is just the new norm your
answer is what well I think what we need
to say is you know sure adults do it
right and that's a completely different
ballgame because they're about the age
of 18 I think that what we need to
appreciate is that norms are created in
part by rules and so if we have no rules
saying don't ask for pictures we're not
creating the norms we want to create so
I think we need to actually take that
extra step and make a rule for all
teenagers girls and boys so don't ask
for these pictures and it's an
uncomfortable subject matter for for
teens and for parents and teachers to be
discussing but very important it is and
I think it's one that they've been
dealing with largely without adult
support and we owe them support for how
they're gonna conduct their
relationships now because that leg of
lays the groundwork for how they're
going to conduct their relationships as
adults it's a great tips Lee so thank
you so much welcome thanks for having me